like they could be but it's just they
don't have the right girl to become that
exactly what what mistakes do you see
girls make that takes them out of the
running to be wives
um I don't know I just wanna
if I could just
simply say it well if they're if they
could easily get sucked into things like
feminism like you know overall yeah I
know people say oh but there's this type
of feminism
you know I think we could all agree that
all this like men are trash and all that
stuff that's probably the biggest
mistake if you can if you can allow that
in
you know in your mindset and think that
that's okay that's probably the biggest
one